hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich sage euch
direkt was sache ist wir machen heute
die try to get the ending challenge also
die versuche das ende zu erraten
challenge bei der es darum geht dass man
ein video gezeigt bekommt einen kurzen
ausschnitt der läuft dann an und bevor
irgendwas wichtiges passiert oder halt
eben nicht probiert man dann zu erraten
was passieren wird klingt ist vielleicht
ein bisschen kompliziert die video idee
habe ich von jana die hat mir nämlich
gesagt hey das ist ein video was ich
selbst auf youtube gesehen habe voll
cool dann hab ich gedacht ja das klingt
echt cool habe danach gesucht aber
nichts gefunden es gibt eigentlich
irgendwie fertige videos auf die man
reagieren kann und das war mein problem
und anhalt andré vom kanal andre akkari
ganz oben verlinkt gesagt damit du das
video machen kann es schneide ich dir
schnell was zusammen und hat mir zehn
solcher szenarien rausgesucht die ich
mir jetzt im video anschauen kann es
gibt immer vier auswahlmöglichkeiten wie
dieses video ausgehen kann und das ist
eigentlich auch schon alles so leid wir
sehen hier eine rallye und alle fahrt
das ist tatsächlich schon der punkt an
dem ich mich entscheiden muss das war
doch nur eine sekunde
also ich hab ja nichts verdächtiges
gesehen ich würde sagen wir gehen noch
mal rein
[Musik]
okay sie ziehen halt alle an dieser
stelle so in diese kurve rein ob das
jetzt bedeutet dass es dann unfall geben
wird okay gucken wir uns mal die
antwortmöglichkeiten an
möglichkeit eins mehrere autos fahren
ineinander und fangen an zu brennen
möglichkeit zwei es gibt einen unfall
und am ende liegen zwei autos
aufeinander
möglichkeit drei alle autos vor allem
normal weiter möglichkeit vier keine der
oben genannten sachen also es wird
definitiv eine der oben genannten sachen
seien deshalb schließlich die letzte
sache schon mal aus was ihr auf jeden
fall gerne machen könnte ist einfach mit
raten in den kommentaren weil das ist
glaube ich so ein video wo man das
richtig gut machen kann schreibt einfach
die nummer eins und dann eins zwei drei
oder vier raten einfach mal so während
des videos ein bisschen mit wenn ich auf
jeden fall interessant ob wir da
vielleicht besser oder schlechter drin
sein als ist die wahrscheinlichste
variante ist wahrscheinlich dass mehrere
autos ineinander fahren und anfangen zu
brennen
dass zwei autos aufeinander liegen wenn
ich schon krass gucken wir einfach mal
also ich glaube nummer eins die autos
fahren ineinander und fangen an zu
brennen
was passiert als nächstes jahr das
wollen wir auch gerne wissen was läuft
weiter und nein nein das gibt es doch
nicht
leute seht ihr das das war das denn
gerade wie unwahrscheinlich das ist halt
so eine sache da kann man glaube ich
richtig gut daran erkennen ob es sich
tatsächlich um eine richtige antwort
handeln was zu unwahrscheinlich ist dann
keine ahnung ist es höchstwahrscheinlich
der fall
[Musik]
alter folgend dass das untere auto ist
noch folgen
und er steht einfach auf den berg er ist
das gestrickt wird oder ist das echt
aber das kannst du das kannst du nicht
fähig eigentlich mit so vielen autos das
echt ok als nächstes geht es weiter mit
einem anderen auto das einfach in einem
see also einfach ist jetzt nicht so dass
alle welt szenario dass so ein auto
einfach in einem see drin steht oder was
auch immer das ist okay also das dem
prinzip wieder auch nur eine sekunde die
wir hier sehen was passiert als nächstes
also wenn ich versuche ohne dass
formularen irgendwas zu denken habe ich
absolut keine ahnung was soll schon
passieren das auto versinkt im schlamm
oder löwen fangen an das auto zu
umkreisen wo mich ja eine schlange
springt gegen die kammer ob gott ich
würde mich so krass erschrecken oder
keiner der oben genannten sachen
feuerwehr punkt 4 ist also rennen weiß
köln halt alle drei punkte erfunden sein
und es kann immer keine der oben
genannten sachen sein
ich glaube es aber auch hier wieder
nicht ich denke mal das auto versinkt im
schlamm
entweder es versinkt oder eine schlange
springt gegen die kamera schauen wir
einfach mal rein
ich lege mich jetzt mal fest auf die
schlange weil ich glaube nicht dass das
auto so schnell versinkt
[Musik]
ist es ernst was ja was ist das denn
gewesen lobte einfach dieser junge und
holt das ding geht geht euch mal wie
perfekt das aussieht so mit diesem
komischen baum da hinten und der bank
zumindest dachte ich das ist das ist
aber kommt der typ einfach und hilft das
spielzeugauto auf das ganze was geht
jetzt ab okay also es war keine der oben
genannten möglichkeiten hättet ihr es
gewusst schreibt nun die kommentare ich
glaube kaum so weiter geht s hier ist
ein pferd auf einer pferdekoppel was
passiert jetzt großartiges breitet
einfach und läuft zu irgendwas an
ich denke mal nicht dass es einfach nur
hürden nehmen wird antwortmöglichkeiten
das pferd springt über den zaun und haut
ab dass fährt fliegt hin und rutscht
zehn meter also genug geschwindigkeit
hätte es auf jeden fall
das pferd wird von einem riesigen ball
getroffen oder keine der oben genannten
sachen also riesiger teil wäre jetzt mal
richtig asozial wenn man irgendwie so
ein pferd damit abwerfen würde über den
zaun springen und abhauen ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich dass es hinfliegt kann
halt auch passieren ich würde eigentlich
fast sagen dass es über den sound
springt und abhaut ist so zu normal
glaube deshalb fliegt hin auch wenn es
mir wahrscheinlich in der seele weh tut
das jetzt anzuschauen aber ja gucken wir
mal
ist zwar richtig meine also es tut das
richtig gut drauf zu sehen
genau das muss leider korrigieren ist
sind glaube ich keine zehn meter ich
wage mal zu behaupten dass das jetzt
nicht so super schlimm ist weil ich
meine der natur passiert halt auch dass
ein pferd mal hin fällt oder erstes mal
dass ich eine richtige antwort habe und
wir sehen jetzt eine situation die
anscheinend einen streit ist so wie wird
sich zurück geschubst und jetzt schon
einiges mitgemacht hätte er macht so
richtige karate muss guckt euch mal an
der der jungen gelben oberteil schlägt
den anderen mit einem schlag der junge
im schwarzen oberteil zieht ein messer
ein lehrer greift ein und sie beide mit
einem move gleichzeitig auf dem boden
oder aber keiner der oben genannten
sachen in diesen videos ist eigentlich
voll häufig so dass der aggressor also
der typ der stress macht dann
ausgeknockt wird weil es dann so
satisfied sage ich mal ist entscheidend
ist er hier der rest also der schutz den
anderen und dann geht der andere im
kampfmodus also ich tippe darauf dass
ein lehrer kommt und die beiden umhaut
schenke meistens der lehrer und
tja leute ist schon wieder dieses
verflixte keine der oberen antworten das
ist richtig gemein das kann halt alles
sein na ja gucken aber weiter was als
nächstes kommt so der typ hier bist auf
einmal das ist wieder über eine sekunde
und alles auf der welt kann passieren
aber wir brauchen wieder die
antwortmöglichkeiten verantwortlichkeit
1 das auto fängt an zu driften ist doch
schon aus der kurve raus wer komisch
zwei das auto wird von einem anderen ram
kann gut passieren das auto fällt in
zwei teile kann auch passieren keine der
oben genannten sachen kann sowieso
passieren
ich denke mal wie sieht das auto aus
könnt ihr das auseinanderfallen
an sich wäre es ja auch mal krass wenn
irgendwas unerwartet etwas unspektakulär
auskommen würde deshalb sage ich einfach
mal nicht passieren
ich wollte sagen das trifft aber es
fällt auseinander los geht's es trifft
zwar so ein bisschen in die kurve rein
aber das pferd dann gerade warum soll es
anfangs zu driften
ja sehr gut sehr sehr gut das auto fährt
tatsächlich auseinander dann habe ich
tatsächlich schon mal einen zweiten
punkt bei fünf sachen 52 punkte ok als
nächstes irgendwie rohr arbeiten oder so
okay er dreht einfach eine wasser hat
was sind die antwortmöglichkeiten das
wasser spritzt komplett ins gesicht eine
schlange kommt aus dem wasserhahn es
läuft schlamm aus dem wasserhahn oder
keine der oben genannten sachen ort
kommt garantiert irgendwas aus dem
wasserhahn nicht einfach nur wasser in
sich dass wir jetzt so unspektakulär
aber ist es eine schlange oder schlamm
ich tippe auf schlamm und was kommt bei
der letzten sache haben es noch gesagt
wäre doch voll krass wenn mal was
unspektakulär es kommt es ist einfach
nur wasser war das eine
antwortmöglichkeit nee aber es ist keine
der oben genannten sachen na super hat
er mich ist auf jeden fall richtig
schwierig weil es einfach nicht nur so
ein ratespiel ist so werde mit einer
pusteblume habe ich hier noch eine
in ägypten gibt dem jungen eine
pusteblume oder kenne ich so ganz viele
videos wo die die kinder die pusteblumen
verschlucken weil sie falsch vom pusten
und so also der junge ist die blume
junge dreht sich um und schenkt die
blume einem anderen mädchen der junge
schmeißt die blume auf den boden und
tritt drauf keine der oben genannten
sachen
ich sage 1 oder 2 also entweder ist er
sich oder dritte und verschenkt die
erfreut sich ja auch um nimmt die so mit
freude entgegen
die blume ich sage einfach mal er ist
sie weil ich das schon häufig gesehen
habe so
das ist tatsächlich mein dritter punkt
leute ich bin richtig stolz gerade ich
habe endlich was erreicht zu meinem
leben drei von sieben punkten so als
nächstes eine dash camp bauleute das
muss ich sagen ist passiert mir viel zu
häufig das irgendwie mein ganzes leben
lang auf solchen des camps street fails
channels unterwegs bin und mir einfach
da alles rein ziehen aber ja machen wir
hier
da passiert das krasseste zeug immer
also antwortmöglichkeiten ein tiger
rennt auf die straße es kommt eine große
schlamm wolke aus dem boden andere du
und dein schlamm andere schreibt immer
irgendwas von schlangen ist das dritte
mal schon möglichkeit drei ein anderes
auto und ein motorrad bauen einen unfall
oder keine der oben genannten sachen
tiger glaube ich irgendwie nicht große
schlamm wolke könnte schon sein ohr wo
ist also das auto und ein motorrad bauen
einen unfall unspektakulär doch ich sag
schlamp jetzt muss endlich mal was mit
schlamm kommen habt ihr das gesehen
leute kunst direkt nochmal
wahnsinnig da ist der schlamm sind vier
aus acht leute jetzt geht es richtig ich
habe echt gesagt kam dass viele von euch
auch so verraten haben irgendwie schon
gut so die hälfte jetzt habe ich
mittlerweile ab zur nächsten ich mich
geheilt oder am see und links ist
irgendwie ein auto möglichkeiten der
folge wird abgeschossen war alle kommen
aus dem wasser das boot wird von haien
angegriffen keine der oben genannten
sachen haie glaube ich nicht vor gewinn
abgeschlossen wer folgt er vertraulich
war alle kommen aus dem wasser
ich sage diesmal keine der oben
genannten sachen soll habe ich noch nie
gesagt jetzt
oh mein gott als listiger dembski moment
kommen wir noch mal da sind irgendwie
erste fliegende fische ich dachte schon
ja hast recht gab
dann kommt 3d vier wale auf einmal
hochgekommen aus dem wasser ja
tatsächlich ich dachte war alle gleich
und das boot an aber hier greifen das
boot an also leider keinen punkt habe es
auch eine möglichkeit noch einen letzten
punkt zu machen so wir haben diesen man
hier in seinem boot
[Musik]
oder besser muss schiefgehen das muss
schiefgehen er will aus dem fahrenden
kano aussteigen das kanu wird von vögeln
angegriffen
der fahrer wird von einem nackten mann
umgeworfen er fällt betrunken auf dem
steg oder keine der oben genannten
sachen der fahrer wird von einem nackten
mann umgeworfen
[Musik]
ja man tatsächlich geschafft leute damit
habe ich fünf von zehn erreicht wer kann
mir das nachmachen dann würde ich sagen
leute ich hoffe sehr das video hat euch
gefallen es war wirklich sehr sehr
spannend falls ihr davon noch einen
zweiten part sehen wollt dann schreibt
mir das nun die kommentare oder zeigt
sich mit einer bewertung spitze kommt
unbedingt bei andere dem ehrenmann
vorbei dafür dass er dieses video
gemacht hat dass das zusammengeschnitten
haben würde mich sehr freuen hat er sich
verdient und ja dann euch noch einen
schönen tag ich schneide das video jetzt
für euch hier gibt es ein altes video
und hier unten könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren und dann bis zum nächsten mal
was war das für ein komischer begrüße
und ab macht was auch immer